former NASCAR driver now analyst on NBC
Dale Earnhardt jr. and joining us now he
filmed a new video series with Nicorette
encouraging family and fans and family
to quit smoking I didn't know that you
know it was a I was talking to Nate Ryan
today and it was sort of a secret but a
lot of people in the industry knew it
but nobody sort of outside that NASCAR
bubble knew it that I was a smoker I
smoked for 15 years just picked it up as
a habit hanging out my friends and it
became like a pack and a half a day
after 15 years and so I've been
smoke-free or nonsmoker for over six
years now probably quit about eight
years ago I know it's and and so what
did you do on race day I just didn't
smoke you know I didn't smoke in the car
I think that you know I could go you
know chunks of time if I had to like a
long caution could you fire up a hero no
I couldn't do that yeah I know I would
have never brought this to the to light
had Nicorette not came to me and said
man we've got a new product and we would
like you to help us so to tell the world
about it it's a coated ice mint lozenge
and it's not a gum and they want to
introduce it to people that are trying
to you know quit so I said yeah I want
to help people I'd love to help people
it sort of goes right along the lines of
us writing that book about the Cushing's
and trying to help people understand
what to do in those situations and I
thought we're great okay if I can tell
my story and it can help somebody quit
or encourage somebody to quit and we
like you say we incur involved in in our
in our production and marketing for this
and and we've got this taste test drive
where I get in a car and take them
around and drive them around and we talk
about my experiences their experiences
and and have them try to product and
hopefully if it gets one person to quit
I mean that's sort of the cliched thing
to say but really if it helps one person
I'm so grateful that's not in my life
right now especially being a husband and
a father trying to quit was impossible I
failed many many times but your wife
knew you were yes she hated it I mean of
course she hated it and
we got to a point in our relationship
where I was trying to quit several times
literally because she wanted me to not
because I wanted to and finally she goes
look Manny you were ever gonna get this
to stop you're gonna get this to stick
and I said I'm not sure I don't know if
I'm ever gonna be a nonsmoker and she
goes oh that's a deal-breaker and
weirdly you were a couple years in our
relationship and I was like really she's
like yeah I think that might be a
problem for me and I said okay I'm gonna
she's too good-looking at night he's
amazing she's the best thing that ever
happened to me so I said I'm I'm giving
it another shot
and and I was you know had more
conviction but had I had a product like
this back then it would have made that
journey way easier and but you have to
be open to change though you gotta
willing to do it yeah you got if you go
kick it in screaming yeah gotta want it
yeah did you did you bring me some
Nicorette I'm like would you bring me
what's in the box then oh well I'm a I'm
a huge fan of yours you know that and I
look up to you and especially becoming a
new broadcaster and I heard about the
news and I'm excited to celebrate that
with you so I brought you this cake
Junior got me a cake congratulations on
the Emmy everybody get up damn that's a
big that's the biggest deal ever in that
that is and that awesome oh we didn't
win oh yeah we didn't we didn't we don't
win the Emmy but I haven't been on
social media I thought you want no we
lost but well that that is really nice
congratulations on almost can we get
almost like heat so junior had somebody
write congrats on winning Emmy yeah I'm
sorry that's all you know it's you can't
really change the writing once of
something cake so it's like well you
still got a cake out of the deal I did
can you return this why would you it's
cake
you know what let's keep this for next
year there you go freeze this for next
year you've won awards before a few UEFA
Cup Awards can we get the cake away from
here cuz I'm afraid it's gonna be in my
face have you ever had somebody throw a
cake in your face this could be today
few minutes it's a nice gesture on
juniors part I'm sorry I'm sorry you
didn't win okay so you how many trophies
you got if I go into your house in my
house there's the bit the most important
ones for me the Bristol trophy the wint
the all-star race both Daytona 500s my
Martinsville clock probably the Dover
win a couple more races Chicago do you
have your own truck just don't have a
case they're just kind of littered in
and around the house and over the years
they let you know you take trophies out
of the house and then they go to Junior
Motorsports or somewhere where they get
displayed maybe the Hall of Fame or
something like that I had to have a
showcase right now for us and so some of
the trophies are over there so and I
think over over the years some trophies
will get out of the house but I always
had like the big stuff just take one
like you have to get out of the house
you got to take one oh if I'm leaving
and ones coming with me yeah no man
well that's tough probably the Daytona
500 win which one the last one the 40
yeah because it's the less tarnished
best-looking one of the two if I said
you can have two Daytona 500 or one Cup
championship I would probably have to
take the championship for sure I mean
when you're honestly it's a championship
is what everybody strives for the
Daytona 500 is is is very special and it
would eat at me if I did not win a
Daytona 500 and won a championship that
would definitely be a hole in in my
heart and butt
but not being a champion there's a void
there as well so you could you know once
you're a champion you sort of are in
this elite group you know and Tony
Stewart's the Optus Hall of Famer
because he's won the Cup Series but not
the Daytona 500 I don't know maybe I
wonder how he feels about not winning
that would he trade the championship or
a championship one of his championships
for Daytona 500 I don't know if he why
don't you text him I don't have my phone
yeah I would you texting you guys number
probably Paulie text
Tony Stewart yeah he just had a birthday
he's probably not feeling very well
today was his birthday
did you ever celebrate with him did you
ever go out and Tony's celebrated many
times how did you just stay on the bus
no no no you know we would be in Vegas
for the awards banquet always got
together afterwards that year that he
had Eddie Vedder come out on stage and
donate to this great charity calls that
they had going on we go I got invited to
go up to this suite later in the night
where it was only Eddie Vedder and Tony
Stewart hanging out and I'm like wow of
all the people you could ask to come up
here so I got to hang out with Eddie
Vedder one of my childhood this guy's a
legend so well you've been in music
videos I have been at a handful I didn't
know that yeah you got that information
right there I think I do somewhere or at
least I I was just surprised because um
I usually don't do homework policy okay
you were in a Nickelback one I was and I
know you know I want to be a rock star I
think was the name of that and I do not
regret that at all I mean that was a lot
of fun and if you look at that video
there are a lot of other people in that
video that we're also get defense named
please excited to be in it as I was out
it's a great song I still like the song
jay-z yeah yeah that was incredible
we got me and Danica Patrick were both
in that video we I was racing at New
Hampshire on Sunday they said we want
you to be in a cup
we want you to be in this jay-z video no
problem where we got to go Monaco
okay that's it it's okay had it when did
we gotta go right after the race so we
got on the plane I ran this race got on
the plane flew straight to Monaco eight
hours didn't sleep got up pounding
coffee we filmed all day long with jay-z
great guy soon as I walk up I'm in
Monica right never been to Monaco never
been to Europe I'm standing there in
Monaco
I see jay-z leaning it on the leaning on
this sort of [ __ ] on the sidewalk so
I'm like ah I'm gonna go over and
introduce myself to jay-z here it goes
so I'm thinking about it I'm walking
over there and as I'm walking over there
I see Beyonce and she's walking towards
jay-z and I'm walking towards jay-z and
I'm like okay if I'm gonna turn around
now's the time this is too much you know
it's like my head was exploding I was
like I had the confidence to meet jay-z
but I don't know if I have the
confidence to meet him but at the same
time and so I get you know get there and
jay-z I'm like hey jay-z I'm Dale he's
like oh thanks for coming so glad you
came all this way and she walks up she's
so nice so I mean by Beyonce right there
is awesome later that night we go this
is Long Street later that night we go to
dinner we're done filming we go to
dinner they invited us to have dinner
with them we're sitting at this big
round table jay-z and Beyonce he's not
there yet we're in this great restaurant
all sudden the roof starts opening up
like a big giant stadium dome roof kind
of opens this roof opening up and it's
stars
we're in Monaco stars roofs open and
jay-z and Beyonce walk in sit down roof
closes for their entrance and they say I
don't they probably had no idea that was
going on but I was like wow man this is
so cool did you think you were famous
until you met that oh yeah I have no
they're on a no totally different level
of Fame and so anyways we sit there and
we had we had beers we ate we talked we
talked like we were sitting on the front
porch of our house it was the best
conversation they are the most
down-to-earth but what did he want to
talk about we they with family okay yeah
racing no we just talked about our crazy
uncles and you know whatever you know
just normal conversation it was just as
as we had known each other for you know
before it's like we'd met before
and Beyonce was so nice I couldn't
believe I mean you know you just they
say don't meet your heroes you know and
some you know when you get the
opportunity she will be a time a cake
and it says congratulate you upset them
yeah but they I was so thankful to had
the had not opportunity because they
were so down-to-earth and their icons
you know they're they're awesome you're
doing the Peace Court in d5 honey
who was gonna do that who was it
Oh Roker Al Roker I was gonna do it
alright so apparently something happened
with his schedule where he couldn't do
it and they call it they called me I'm
gonna be there anyways for NBC to work
I've never been in the Indy 500 they're
like hey would you mind driving the pace
car and I thought me you know I'd love
to Filan for Al Roker and as long as the
Indy car guys are ok with it right cuz
this is you know this is their
playground this is their world all they
reached out to you on Twitter and that
was very nice
yeah I would never want to disrespect
those guys and I was so grateful that
they were happy with it and we're okay
with it because it's a real honor you
know this is a big huge event for those
guys and and I know motorsports and I
know how big this is and I know how and
it's a bucket list item you know I don't
want to you something you can't turn
down when you get those opportunities
how would you have done if you got
Reysol in those cars oh I don't know you
know I hate to get no interest in them
of course very curious always curious
about any kind of race car and what they
drive like an feel like but I hate to
assume that I would get in there and be
great you know I wouldn't never assume
that it's easy or it would come so
natural but it's Stewart made the it was
an e-card driver first okay is it easier
to go that to then to NASCAR I don't
know you know there I would say that
their cars are just a completely
different discipline and it's not
something you just jump in and be great
at it's something like anything else
golf or whatever you have to do all the
time when I talked to Kyle when you talk
if I don't I've never asked Kyle this
but Kasey Kahne Kyle Larson all those
guys that run sprint cars they can't
just go and run the biggest race of the
year and be great they have to run for
months
sort of condition themselves and
understand what's going on in the sport
to be good and to be good when that when
that elite race comes through so you
know it's not something you can just hop
in and oh well I'm a race car driver I
run NASCAR I'm gonna go run the 8500 and
win or even run in the top ten I mean
that shows you what kind of driver Kurt
Busch is excellent race car driver one
of there's only a few guys that can go
like Mario Andretti Tony Stewart even
Kurt Busch that can hop from different
disciplines and be great at it not all
of us can do that I wouldn't assume that
I could do that what's the best thing
you do is the parent oh well yeah I
don't know I I don't know I think I
think I'm pretty good at it you do you
read stories you change diapers like
what do you do well I be your buddy you
know our friend like mom moms got to
keep things in line mom's got to keep
her doing right from wrong mom's got a
mom's gotta you know be Stern and I get
to go in there just beer buddy and play
you know I don't I don't have the hard
job I have the new discipline ER yeah
yeah oh yeah I mean I don't have a prado
have a problem sort of helping because
she's in that phase where it's I think
it's real important she's 13 months
right now and I think it's super
important to not let an opportunity to
learn go by like when she makes a
mistake or just like the other day we
were hanging out and she's eating rocks
and I'm like I'm good
we need to wait wait you had to look up
well I'm riding Roxbury no I'm googling
like what's the protocol here do I need
to really be really aggressive obviously
I don't want to eaten rocks I'm yeah I'm
getting the rocks out when she's trying
to put the rocks in but I'm just trying
to make sure I don't know I'm just
trying to figure out whether I need to
be super concerned is this is this you
know how critical is this situation
where's to accidentally swallow a small
pebble is this something we need to rush
the hospital me where's mom she's there
Oh shoes yeah
she's helping she's not as concerned as
me obviously because she's
on her phone googling but I'm that
parent I'm gonna be the I'm paranoid
worried to death
mom's like it's not a big deal wait till
she's a teenager that will just what
happens that's when the tough part three
five three daughters yeah and that's
when you know what the best thing you
can do is have a have a relationship
where you she knows she can always talk
to you yeah in it and it sounds simple
but it's the best thing I ever did with
my daughters is they they talk to you
about everything and if you have that
relationship then they don't hide
anything they're still hide stuff but
they are open to conversation and they
don't look at you like oh god I got to
tell you but if you can keep the lines
of communication open certainly with a
teenage girl yeah you'll be ahead of the
game I'll try my best I mean I think
we're gonna have a great relationship
and any we got a anything else coming
you got another kid coming no no okay I
thought you know I mean if we have
breaking news would be nice to announce
that yeah I mean I don't know where is
there something much I don't know is
there well know if you don't know that
I'm surprised for me no no their kids
bring in Amy
hey good how can people get involved in
this the Nicorette absolutely yeah if
you want to take the taste test drive go
to Nick read calm we it's a lodgings not
a gum tastes great if you're on this
quit journey and you're struggling this
is a great advantage a great tool to put
in your toolbox if I'd have had it and
made that process for me so much better
so much easier and I want to I want to
help people quit you know I know how
rewarding that's been for me how
grateful I am that that's not part of my
life and I know there's a lot of people
out there like me that want to get that
out of their life and and this is gonna
help there's so much that you kept
inside all these years oh yeah I mean
it's like you're you're your
transformation has been unbelievable how
Thanks yeah because of your in your I've
said this before Amy must have done a
great job did and you finding what you
needed to tell people and get it out of
your system yeah I find out you know
when I when I was talking today I was
talking to Amy this morning after we
after we were on a show earlier and I
said you know the funny thing is is in
all this revelation and all these
stories you're in them you're a part of
them you're
heart you're a very key part of my you
know quitting smoking and coming clean
and telling people about it trying to
help people the concussions all those
things that I went through amy was this
key figure in it and it's been
incredible it's great to see you thank
you and uh congrats on oh you gave these
one day oh yeah yeah and next year
wouldn't we win the Emmy yes then we
bring out the kids I don't want to win a
frickin Emmy I want to be even I want to
be a nominated or whatever happens good
lord you guys should be proud
don't get greedy okay I didn't win a
Daytona 500s don't man think about a
sports having four more Dan Patrick show
tune in the audience channel 239 on
DirecTV stream for free on BR live or
download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]